bonjour bakary traoré j merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct de bamako ce
matin dans la matinale berthet france un
coup d'état dans le coup d'état
hier comment est ce que la population
malienne a vécu ce nouveau coup de force
ben écoute et là on était les maliens et
d'une manière générale et bien assisté
mousseline on a vécu ce coup de force
des militaires comme si c'était une
force d'une forme de résignation sous
forme de résignation en quelque sorte
ou alors quelque chose auquel la
population s'attendait dès lors que
djian la citation
elle voulait des telle sorte que et bien
les populations vis cela comme si
c'était une sorte de guéguerre entre des
chefs au sommet de l'état et qu'elle n'a
pas d'emprise là dessus mais cela dit
quand on regarde un a retrospective la
situation était telle que et bien le
gouvernement sortant le communiste
horrible du prix ministre ottawan même
temps la situation politique qui
prévalait
c'est à dire le dialogue de sourds qui
s'est installé entre la classe politique
d'une part mais aussi les acteurs
sociaux comme le signe que la centrale
des l'union nationale des travailleurs
du mali eh bien on voyait que ya une
sorte de crise et bien qu'ils pouvaient
et finalement qui a éclaté avec cette
éruption une fois de plus des militaires
sur la scène politique qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont choqué comment justifie t-il
ce coup de force les militaires dans le
communiqué qui a été lu et qui a été
signé par le vice président à signer le
colonel racing white a il explique cette
ce coup de force heures par le fait que
et bien les présidents la transition
banda et son premier ministre moctar
ouane essayé de saboter en quelque sorte
les suites de cette transition dans la
mesure où la mise en place du nouveau
gouvernement
parce que le prévenu sur le sortant a
été reconduit par le plus d'embarras il
a été chargé donc de constituer une
nouvelle équipe pour finir finalement la
transition et les militaires ont estimé
que dix n'ont pas été consultés ils
n'ont pas été associés à cette démarche
pour constituer la nouvelle équipe
d'autant plus que le vice-président a
des prérogatives que la charge de la
transition et lui conférait donc
rugueuse c'était une sorte de un peu des
mises à l'écart du fait que le bris
ministre monte à roanne et le président
banda a effectuée à leur endroit
mais bon quand on essaie de voir aussi
d'une manière générale
il explique aussi la situation de telle
sorte que bien la centrale syndicale des
travailleurs du mali donc avaient
déclenché une grève de deux semaines
plus de toujours aussi j'avais la grève
n'arrive pas à aboutir ou quoi
satisfaire leurs revendications et sans
tenir compte aussi également donc la
situation délétère au niveau sécuritaire
du pays
d'un côté tous ces éléments ont été
avancés par les militaires d'une manière
générale par rapport à cette situation
mais quand vous souvenez leurs émissions
précédentes interventions c'est votre
cher à l'époque au moins depuis le coup
d'état du 18 août j'avais publié que la
façon dont la télé a été prévu il
fallait s'y attendre un moment à un
autre
sade et l'empiétement des prérogatives
entre le président de la république le
président de la transition et son vice
président et si c était le cas
l'autre jour à la situation sanitaire
que vous évoquez est extrêmement fragile
o malié on a entendu les appels de la
communauté internationale à la
libération notamment de ses dirigeants
vous pensez que ça va être le cas est ce
que vont ils être libérés selon vous
rapidement
et qu'en est il de la situation
sécuritaire ça laisse un vide et ça
laisse une instabilité politique peu
propice à à résoudre ce problème
eh bien à mon avis aux questions ça
résume intéressante une seule seconde
que la question centrale c'est à dire la
sortie de crise comment va sortir de
cette crise à mon avis soit on va passer
par une sorte de soft power
c'est à dire que la classe politique la
société civile et les militaires vont se
retrouver pour dégager une solution
consensuelle à l'interné et la deuxième
solution envisageable sa piètre power
c'est à dire que et bien la communauté
internationale va imposer des sanctions
des méthodes coercitives à la junte de
telle sorte que est bien le président
sortant bendaho et sont prévenus ou
alors un autre prisme soit reconduit
la tête de l'état ou alors il ya une
troisième solution envisageable c'est à
dire que c'est la considération de cette
solution
la classe politique la société civile et
les militaires vont se retrouver pour
dégager une solution consensuelle
quitte à ce que eh bien on supprime la
poste de vice-président en ce moment le
président le vice-président de connexion
également en tout cas on a eu
l'essentiel avec bakary traoré ce matin
bakary traoré qu'on a retrouvée
finalement je voulais se terminer votre
propos sur sûre et les solutions de
cette sortie de crise on n'a pas entendu
votre dernière phrase je disais que donc
c'était la troisième solution
envisageable c'est à dire que la classe
politique la société civile et militaire
pour le dégager une solution
consensuelle mais avec l'accompagnement
de la communauté internationale afin que
le cas des 18 - soit maintenue
oui la communauté internationale qui est
très active notamment contrôlé sur la
lutte contre le terrorisme
au mali les groupes jihadistes ont
profité de ce vide politique selon vous
avez si possible une solution posible
délire peu et bien la citation sécurité
donc s'est aggravée du nord jusqu'au
centre mais aussi qu'ils appuient de
connotations n'est que parfois au niveau
du centre je pense que il ya tous ces
inquiétudes qui pèsent sur l'issue des
neuf mois qu'il reste au bouquet la
transition merci beaucoup bakary traoré
d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt frange rappelle que
vous êtes est directeur de publication
du site
malik aux infos en direct de bamako